the World Endurance Championship reached
its finale and Porsche bade farewell to
the llama prototype one class at the
2017 six hours of Bahrain
it's a very emotional day for Porsche
and a wonderful time it's a highlight
for his career as a Porsche driver and
he feels more pride and joy than sadness
Porsche had already nailed the world
championship title in the season's next
to last race in Shanghai but the team
wasn't ready to rest on its laurels
Porsches only competitor in the lmp1
class was Toyota yeah well we're going
into this race to try and win yeah we've
won four races this year in car number
eight but the competitors drove hard to
the very end endurance racing demands
everything from the team's Lemann driver
han soo-ah from stroke endurance racing
is good fun and teamwork from the first
driver to the last mechanic everyone has
to work together to win he points out
that after Formula One the WEC is the
technically and most demanding series he
has lots of fun with all the classes
lmp1 lmp2 GTE & GT they bring everything
together with the latest technology even
with the stress leading up to the start
the drivers still find time for their
fans will get a chance to collect
autographs during what's known as the
pit walk
this part of the racing event appeals to
young and old alike in the last two
minutes of the qualifying rounds Porsche
managed to secure positions one and
three Toyota claimed to at four
driver needle Jonny was a bit surprised
himself they got quite a run for their
money against Toyota in the qualifying
and weren't expecting to earn their pole
positions in the very last race as the
Sun descends over behind that cars are
off the second Porsche takes the lead in
the very first curve with such big
variations in performance between the
four classes many of the cars end up
lapping each other which makes it more
exciting but can also complicate matters
speed is of the essence for pit stops -
teamwork and precision mean everything
here tires have to be changed and the
tank filled before the car heads back
onto the track
the race is head-to-head with the four
lmp1 cars constantly jockeying for
position
as the hours tick past the suspense
rises in the Porsche pit flat tires and
flattened cones on the tracks load the
Porsches down the number 8 Toyota takes
home the victory while Porsche land 2nd
and 3rd even so the Porsche team has
reason to celebrate
their results from three years in the
lmp1 are three Lemann outright victories
plus three manufacturers and three
drivers world championship titles
welcome Porsche sees it as an incredible
success thanks in part to a healthy dose
of luck he's sure his father would have
been especially happy he always said
that they had to do motorsports because
they got so many innovations and
improvements from it and so it pays off
Hachi cows get side
michelle steiner predicts they'll keep
driving their 911s at least as
intensively and the GTS even more so
porsche
intends to reflect its product strategy
for a move toward electric drive and
motorsports as well so they've decided
in addition to building the mission a
production car to pursue motorsports in
the formula e electric auto racing